so I'm a massive Bridgeton fan and I'm
so relieved that I love you too in this
show together you guys are so good thank
you so much
you know you both have this incredible
task of bringing this epic love story to
to life you each have characters that go
through their own personal struggles you
boast your very intimate scenes together
is there a moment that stands out to
each of you where you realize okay this
person has my back I can trust this
person
that is a great question question
unfortunately working with India
they were a few and far between those
moments
um I'll be honest with you uh India is
phenomenal and always always has my back
um but but one moment
would be
would be I tell you what there was a
moment in a scene where
we were it's just after a ball and uh
this this is a very very small thing and
India did much much bigger things for me
but it was just very subtle and she
didn't draw attention to it that uh it
got onto my close-up after about two
hours of filming I and there was someone
in the scene that was moving around and
uh was
at some reason maybe not aware of where
the camera was uh and I was being quite
vulnerable so and then and then would
stand directly between the camera and
myself we kept having to do it over and
over again because you know whatever and
then India just uh pulled pulled uh this
person aside and and made sure to
make my life a lot easier
um and did it in the most graceful way
and um and and then withdrew didn't draw
any attention to herself didn't make it
about her it was yeah
solid solid sorry that's such a good
story India do you have one no
[Music]
um I think probably in rehearsal
um is when I I first realized I was like
okay I can trust this guy because he had
such he just cared so much about the
project and I'd been in drama school
before with
um a lot like a couple of of
um male actors and there was always they
were always a little bit too shy to put
their whole heart into it because it's
quite vulnerable and it's quite scary
and Corey was just very upfront and like
I really care about this project I want
to throw it all and I was like he's in
it so now I'm invested as well and I and
I want to kind of go in as much as as he
did and um yeah I think we make quite
yeah we do good news
Chemistry Between Love Your characters
it's so good you really feel the love
what do you love about this epic Love
Story between Queen Charlotte and King
George
uh you want to hit us off yeah come
um I think
just that it is I get a true I don't
know if it's a true love I don't know if
I believe in like you only have one
person and that's your person you know
that's they're only sign to you
um but the fact that they they just
balance each other so well
um and where where George kind of has
flaws or areas where
their room for improvement Charlotte can
age that and then vice versa
um I think they really kind of they
bolster each other up and they they're
they are positive influences in each
other's lives which is really lovely
yeah I basically asked everyone this I
know I got the wrap up real quick one
characteristic you would love if you
were forced to be in an arranged
marriage what when characters would you
love in a partner
[Music]
uh honesty
ooh I like that one I'm all good with
that as well honestly oh you can't go I
can
um trust same thing basically yeah
you are so good in this character and
what's so fun is that you know we follow
up this character for two seasons now we
get to learn so much more about Queen
Charlotte what's been your favorite
thing learning about this character
I think you know to really see behind
the scenes of who this character is and
the wires and the where's and the how
she became the woman that we know and
love in Bridgeton you know
um so that's the kind of broader wider
aspect of it a more kind of intimate uh
aspect of it is the relationship that
she has with brimsley that relationship
is so um important and integral to her
Hugh and i q sax who plays brimsley we
have worked so hard on creating that
relationship
um that you never see and you never hear
in Bridgeton so now we're able to really
show that and show the love and the
dedication
um that these two people have for each
other
is it just me or the wigs getting bigger
and better yeah the wigs are getting
bigger better and heavier
I tell you that yeah
you handle that they are works of art
and I am on this I'm working on a
campaign at the moment to uh get them to
have their own um tour around the world
and an exhibition of Queen Charlotte's
wigs and costumes I think yeah yeah yeah
yeah the world needs this I know yeah
I'd go and see it definitely it was it
was really weird the um I think it was
last night when I went to the Bridgeton
experience they had one of the costumes
that I wore in season two and I had no
recollection of it at all and you know
my first kind of talk about these uh
extraordinary iconic looks was that
Queen Charlotte will never be in the
same dress or wig twice you know that's
her whole kind of iconic Persona
um and it's yeah it's fabulous it's
really good I feel very honored and
privileged to be able to celebrate these
amazing artists and their work
you know Queen Charlotte obviously was
thrust into this arranged marriage if
this happened to you in real life what
is one characteristic you would want in
a partner if you were to be in an
arranged marriage one characteristic
within a partner I think you can pick
yeah if I could pick I think it would be
one of
solidarity like
I want to say equalness that is that a
word I don't know what I mean by that
but that but that we're both
understanding what it is that's
happening and because
and I think this is something that
Charlotte and George do because they
have been thrust together
they come at it in a way
that's really positive
but also they're really confident with
who they are and I think the respect is
there it's it's kind of a mutual respect
isn't it that they that they both you
know what I mean that they both know
exactly what's happening but that but
let's let's do it with love they're both
striving for that love aren't they and
lucky for them they're on the same level
and they they can they're striving for
the same thing even through adversity
so we fall in love with your take on
Queen Charlotte what do you love about
India's take on this character God so
many so many so many things I love that
she has really embodied and taken the
character for herself you know one thing
that I really supported her in in those
early days was to
to to celebrate her India amatefio you
know in in Charlotte to be her own
person in Charlotte Charlotte you can't
put anything on Charlotte do you know
what I mean she won't allow you to do
that so you have to come come at it with
real openness and real confident with
who you are and India has that in Spades
and I'm so proud every time I watch it
that I see a wonderful beautiful actress
who is firm in who she is in what she's
doing and has taken that role and run
with it I gave it over to her to to love
and respect the whatever way she wanted
that to happen and yeah it's Brava brava
all the way